[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by yael stone aka
ellie in the new amc plus series fire
bite which is premiering this thursday
how are you doing today
i'm so great and look i'm just wondering
where your blonde wig is that's my main
question
you know i was thinking about wearing a
wig for this but i didn't know if you
would like that but okay i'll check next
time i talk to you i'm wearing a wig
yeah i'm very weak partial so please
okay you you got it i love that um
so
you know people are gonna love to see
you in this it's exciting because it's
like this fantasy vampire series
were you somebody who was a fan of that
type of genre either fantasy or vampire
before this is there any like specific
shows or movies you're kind of into that
well
you know i think from so many people and
i'm yet to understand why
there is a like deeply
sensual
slash sexual crossover with vampires i
don't know if that that's how our show
is going but i think for me um
i remember watching interview with the
vampire as a kid and being like
oh i have some funny feelings about this
[Music]
um
that yeah those were some particularly
sensual vampires so that's my earliest
memory of vampires um but i'm a real
scaredy cat to be perfectly honest like
and the world of vampires is
particularly frightening for me um i
think as a child i used to um pretend
that there were vampires at the window
and and that i had to go to sleep
otherwise they were gonna get me and
that's how i you know used to make
myself go to sleep
oh wow
i've never said that out loud
that's a weird thing to share but yeah i
i think i'm quite a scaredy cat so it
was a bit scary working on this show
there were definitely moments i was
pretty freaked out
sure and i'm assuming then you're also
not like crazy about gore in general or
is that something that
gets your blood flowing
my mom is a nurse so i always like
wanted to be like her and be like very
cool about stitches or whatever yeah it
doesn't hurt or it's not grossing me out
so gore is different i feel differently
about gore it's more like
ghosts
definitely ghosts which is
now i kind of like witches as a grown-up
um vampires zombies
that's kind of my hitting zone of freaky
okay got you ah no
unsolved mysteries
yes i do oh yeah yeah so i think i
watched one of them as a child and then
i was just ruined for the rest of my
life like yeah i'm got my imagination is
too much
no that that makes complete sense but
it's cool that you're in a show like
this i think that's awesome and you know
people will see in it uh that you are
playing a bartender ellie um
what is the process for you though like
just in a role like this like
are you those like extreme prep where
you're like becoming one with the bar
and learning how to make the drinks or
is it not that intense am i am i going
too far here
um
do you know
see i i think it's probably hard to talk
about the character particularly for you
because those first three episodes like
the characters not in much of the show
let's be honest um so so we don't get to
know ellie as much as as we do later on
um
so i guess i would answer that by saying
that for me
it's more about getting into the
intricacies of
uh her emotional
world and not so much the practicalities
of the bar
if the bar was central to who she is
then yes i would do that you know if i
was playing a photographer who's whose
whole way of looking at the world was
informed
by being a photographer then yes i would
want to invest in that craft but i don't
really think that ellie's whole vibe is
about pouring shots and pulling beers
but look i have worked in a bar i will
say and i have
uh worked in restaurants and i
understand the shitty aspects of the
service industry so i consider those
things pre-researched
yeah no that that's a great answer and
yeah that makes complete sense where
that's coming from and
yeah i mean look everything that you do
even though like you said you're not in
it too much yet it's still really good
stuff to watch it exciting
yeah i know there's a mystery to your
character which i like too um so i'm
excited for the more episodes to come
but
for you
being in the show and as an actress in
general in your career are you someone
now when this comes out like do you get
the family around the like tv and watch
it or you do not like watching yourself
like how are you about that
i i am always excited about
seeing other people's work which
includes the editor's work and the
director's work and uh and how the
soundtrack is coming together and so
that is always a great joy for me
actually to to watch when something's
put together like of course i feel
self-conscious
um but i think after years and years of
of doing this job you do
kind of learn to like okay
yes i'm gonna feel self-conscious and
weird but also there's all these other
aspects of the show that i just
desperately want to see and i'm
fascinated about
um
you know what it feels like to shoot a
scene and then how what it feels like
when it comes together um and how it's
come together and the edit is so
important you know and particularly with
a show like this um the rhythms i mean
with every show but but
genre wise
in terms of like fight sequences all
this kind of stuff
it's amazing to to watch things come
together and with with
with people like like warwick and
brendan who have such a clear vision of
of this show that they've created um
the
it's kind of like they're the taste
masters of of this world and i'm
thrilled to see how they pulled it
together
yeah and and that's so awesome and such
a smart answer because it's showing you
two also how much you appreciate every
part of film and love it and that that's
really cool to hear that
oh that's that's like my that's the the
whole
reason why i like being on a set um
because there are so many people at work
with very very very specific skills and
we need every one of those skills
in their in everyone's specific world to
lock in perfectly and that's a lot to
ask like it's a miracle to get a tv show
or a film made you know it's a miracle
but then to actually make it and make it
good
it's a it's a whole other miracle oh
yeah
i love the team aspect
yeah and speaking of you also talking
about being on set i i was watching this
and thought how beautiful just the
desert landscape was in this show and
the scenery where exactly is this in the
world this being filmed i'm curious it's
um it's a little old town called cuba pd
um
c-o-o-b-e-r
p-e-d-y
okay and
writing this down yeah i mean it's worth
a visit
it is a wild place
it's in the middle of australia it's
kind of halfway between
uh
uluru and
adelaide it is
there is no reason for it to exist
beyond opals from what i can tell
um there are 240 000 abandoned opal
mines in the area you could just go
missing like that um
yeah it's it's a wild place and um
yeah it was very cool to be there
yeah i mean it looks sick and i i think
that um that's such a big part of the
show too and you're talking about all
these parts being important just the
cinematography and again whoever scouted
out that location it's it's great work
and um yeah it comes together
beautifully and my last question for you
i have to ask being a big orange is the
new black fan um
did that kind of change your life for
good or for worse in a sense that like
do you feel like because it was such a
massive hit does it mess with your head
a little bit now or do you want
everything to be that big or is it kind
of have you found a nice even heel about
it
oh
that's
i think probably no one's asked me that
before
um
i think i no i would never change
anything about that experience it was a
beautiful creative experience life
experience it was a great um you know
test of of the the uglier parts of your
ego um you know because because it was a
wild hit
and um
and we were right at the beginning of
that netflix kind of birth
and so we just got to see
something that will probably never
happen in that way again
and i'm very very grateful for it i'm
grateful for the beautiful people that i
met
some of my best friends
um some of the most extraordinary
experiences
the acting lesson that i got over seven
years um
i would never change any of it any of it
and the people that i you know fell in
love with in new york the city that i
fell in love with in new york um yeah it
was a magic experience and i would never
have expected it from
you know that day of the first day of
work um you never know what a show is
gonna be
and
and just
i mean
should every show be that i don't know i
don't think it's possible um but i
believe that the work that i that i
choose to do
i believe
i do it because i believe it's it's it's
uniquely special
which is a tautology uniquely special is
a silly thing to say but
but
this show i believe is uniquely special
firebite and that's why i why i chose to
do it um
and
and you know
i don't know success is
the success of a show is kind of
not really in my
in my zone of um of control or thinking
it's more about can we can we tell this
story damn well
can can i contribute in a way that's
going to be like
you know i ask myself can i do can i
really do this job and this character
justice because when i read this script
and i think i don't think we've ever
made this story before i don't think
we've used this metaphor of indigenous
australia and colonial australia and
vampires
with this wit and joy and heart in this
way ever before so that's why i do it
and you know when i was in a different
position in my career when i worked on
orange but i knew that was uniquely
special too i was also damn happy to
have a job um
but
but
you know both i can there's lots of
actual parallels between the the two
shows for me and um in a way
orange taught me
that what you choose to work on
is one of the most important decisions
that you can make and it did shape my
life in pretty unexpected ways
yeah and that that was one of the
biggest gifts
yeah clearly and it's given you a lot of
wisdom and that's a lot of wisdom for
people to hear in general and like you
said
fire bite has that magic too like
orange's new black you've made a great
choice and you see all the hard work put
into including obviously your
performance so for everyone who hasn't
seen it watch yael crush it in firebite
this thursday on amc plus the first
episode comes out and then we'll be
coming out in future weeks as well y'all
thank you so much for joining me today
and i hope to talk to you in the future
again and i promise i'll be wearing a
wig next time can you please and can we
please talk again i would love that yes
i promise it will happen can we talk
let's talk once the rest of the season
comes out can we do that yes we can do
it
mark it on the calendar
have a good one